all the rookies will be there trevor
lawrence will be
at the jaguars rookie mini camp he's
been overshadowed all week by another
guy whose
name begins with a t he is expected to
do some limited work remember he had the
shoulder surgery earlier in the
offseason on the non-throwing shoulder
he's expected to do limited work
whatever that means
when he had the shoulder surgery the
expectation was it was a five to six
month recovery he'd be ready for
training camp training camp still a
couple of months away so i don't know
what limited work means
but he'll be there and he'll start to
learn the offense
and this this reboot of the jaguars
officially
commences with lawrence showing up and
urban meyer
coaching up these jaguars players and
there's the dog that looks just like my
dog
seem yeah look at that hair man that
flow is something else from trevor
lawrence
my goodness what i mean gosh he just he
just looks like a qb one and that's all
he really needs to do this week is just
go over there
stand around maybe do a cup do a press
conference look like a qb one start to
learn the offense and
that's all it really uh refreshment man
i just messed this up
it's rookie it's rookie mini camp but i
like to call it more like freshman
orientation
that's really all this is you just you
come in you get to know the building
you get to know the people who work
around the building you figure out where
your locker is where the cafeteria
is where your meeting room is and you
kind of go out on the field and you have
on a
you have on shorts you have on maybe a
jersey your helmet maybe
and you just start to get the basics of
what it feels like to be in the nfl
and so trevor lawrence probably not
going to need to do all that much this
week that's what training camp is for
that's more what otas are for and we
don't necessarily know how much he's
going to do
with all of that either but look i i
just think that right now
when you're somebody like trevor
lawrence all you got to do is just go in
there and establish that you have a
presence
because once you have that presence of
qb1 that's fine
for the vast majority of teams that do
their training camp at their
regular practice facility you're
absolutely right you're getting a
preview
of what it's going to be like you get an
opportunity to get
your feet wet and and you get a chance
and and i know there's plenty of debates
about
practice speed and practice intensity
and they've got different
levels and they have a pro bowl tempo
whatever that means
but i remember when the late joe
mcknight showed up
for jet's mini camp and ended up puking
all over his shoes
he's getting his first taste of what
it's like
football practice in the nfl that's part
of it too they're going to work you a
little bit now they have backed off some
remember the jaguars several years ago
in his first rookie mini camp what
happened to dante fowler jr
pop goes the acl so teams have learned i
think
let's not throw these guys directly into
fray they're they're they're competitive
they don't care whether it's it's it's
walk through
you want to prove yourself you got guys
going live or close to it and i think
that's going to be another frontier for
this fight
as we push back and we see pushback from
players against
what the teams do but uh it you know
it's it's their first taste of real nfl
football and at some point
and i think this is calculated you want
them to have that moment where they
realize
oh wow this is going to be different
when training camp rolls around
yeah exactly you want them to have that
then as opposed to what happened last
year with guys through no fault of their
own was the pandemic
all right they come in in late july
early august and it's like oh
man like i haven't necessarily exactly
felt like i was an nfl player i mean
i've been sitting
at my computer at my tablet and we've
been going through these meetings and
i've been talking with my new teammates
but now that i'm here it is just a much
different feeling because i see my
locker
i see the helmet i see all these
different things and it really
signals to me that i am in the nfl you
want to get that out of the way as early
as possible so that guys can then just
lock in and say yes
i know what i'm here to do and you know
it's funny because
there are guys who went out there and
had such good rookie years and i kind of
don't know how they did it man
like when you think about everything
that those guys had to go through last
year that was so
different than what they are typically
doesn't herbert
i mean the way that he was able to get
in there in week two and just
really be somebody that we think is now
going to be an elite quarterback i find
that
highly highly impressive and joe burrow
too you know before he got injured he
looked really good but this
this is going to be something different
for these guys where they can come in
there
they can get a little bit of a sense of
normalcy and they can start to establish
themselves as they compete for these
spots on this roster
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports